We've had breaking news. Andrew a lot has happened since our last episode.
Yes. Kamala Harris, vice president Biden,
Harris ticket. Uh, I'm excited. No,
I got to know comma lawyer very well on the rail. It's funny like the,
the different candidates. Uh, you're literally side by side,
uh, in, in the case of me and Commonwealth, I think,
or was it a debate neighbor multiple times now,
one time I smuggled a handkerchief on stage for, uh, she was just like, yay.
I was like, sure. You know, uh, um, but, but more than that,
we, uh,
were in Iowa back to back multiple times, uh,
really much more Iowa than anything else.
Cause she spent a lot of time there and I did too. Um,
but we have each other's, uh, contact info.
I got to know her husband, um, too on the trail. Doug, who's a great guy. Uh,
I'm excited. I think the Biden Harris ticket is really hard to beat,
you know, it's like, it, it feels balanced and comma is a freaking
powerhouse where like she'll, she'll, she will be very,
very strong on the trail and make a lot of people very excited. Uh,
so it it's it's great.
And the most important thing always to me was Joe's desire for the right
partner because he wanted someone, he had the right relationship with.
And it seems like he had a relationship with Kamala from way back because she
was friends with his son Beau and he was attorney general and she was an
attorney general. Uh, so yeah, you know, it, it's a phenomenal picture.
In terms of your relationships with candidates on the trail. You were closest,
I thought with Joe Camila and maybe Tulsi.
Corey Booker, sorry.
You're right. Um, so, uh, I selfishly from Andrew Yang perspective,
this is pretty cool. Cause you're,
you're friendly with her are friends with her. Um,
but thoughts on the strategy of this? Like in what,
what do you think besides do I like the person?
Do I think they're a good leader. What do you think from a political standpoint,
optic standpoint, what are your thoughts on, on the Camila pic?
I think there's a really great balance again, where you have, uh,
Joe who's older than two of Kamala was, uh,
it was like a generation younger. Uh, you have obviously the gender dynamic,
the race dynamic, uh, it's very balanced. Uh,
there's even a little bit of an East coast, West coast thing going.
The, the right. I watched Fox news last night,
cause I'm always so interested in what they say about the VP pick and they
already have tried to brand her and bench Bureau came out.
Same thing said comma is a radical lefty.
And to me that branding does not stick.
I think she's really as moderate as they come.
I think it's insane to try and call her that. I mean, yes,
she's had some California policies she's kind of been wrapped up in or just by
being us Senator from the San Francisco or Bay area, um, is one thing,
but he an attorney general, uh, there is no,
she's a very moderate sensible politician. Um, so I think that won't stick.
I don't know, to me she's already been branded and throwing the nonsense at her.
Won't stick the way it might with some of the other lesser known VP candidates
he was considering.
Yeah. I think they have to try that. I don't think it's correct or effective.
Uh, but you know, at this point they're in desperation mode.
Yeah. It was, it was fascinating like Hannity and Laura Ingram were like,
this is the most radical ticket that Democrats have ever run. And you're like.
I really think that's correct.
Oh, I don't know how many moderates are really watching Fox news anymore,
but I don't, I don't know. But, um, that doesn't feel right.
So congrats to Camila and her team. Um, and I'm,
I'm excited. I think this is a solid pick and we're and look, the other thing,
the other fact,
the other piece of this is that all of the Democrats fell in line,
which I think is rare. Like we usually have rifts in our party. Um,
and that was nice to see the rest of the democratic leadership and candidates
all come out and support her and Joe with you pick.
Yeah. I agree.
Congrats to Kamala and Doug and the whole team and win this thing.
Yeah. So we're going to help, which is exciting,
which brings me to other forms of helping and probably one of the reasons many
of you tuned in because yesterday hashtag let yang
speak DNC was trending.
I think it got up to number three in politics and trader,
but it was like it's top 10 and Twitter, at least in the United States.
So that the high level overview is that the DNC came out with their ma let's
call it their speaker card. Um,
of who's speaking all four days during the DNC convention.
And we were left off that list,
which was a bit of a shock to us because we've been in conversations with the
DNC, um,
about speaking and have been given what seems to be some prime time slots
throughout the week. We are expected to speak at the convention, be a member.
So, and then you tweeted out, um, you know, if I'm honest,
I was expecting to speak in a sense of,
should speak with the people on that list. So your react,
I think the world is interested in your, your real reaction and also why this,
um, why this matters to you and to frankly, our supporters.
I commented to a journalist that it's not like you or
me were jumping up and down, like yelling at anyone's ear, being like, Oh,
we need this spot. We need that. That's not. Uh, yeah. Um,
but that there is like a real sense that we have a lot of people that, uh,
supported my campaign. Many of whom were on the fence about Joe. Uh,
and I've been telling them we need to get by and Joan, uh, get Trump out.
Uh, and I, I said, this makes that case a little bit harder to make,
because one reason why people who supported me would support Joe is like, okay,
if yang is a big part of the team, then we can advance some of the,
um, ideas and policies that I ran on. It's just harder case to make.
If it seems like we are not being included.
Uh, and to your point, it's like,
I thought we were being included that that was like the mystery. And it's like,
Oh, like, Hey, like what, what, what transpires here? I want to be clear.
Listening. It's it's not about us. Um, like, would you like to speak? Sure.
But that's not the point of this.
The point is we have a powerful message and a lot of people that supported it
and wanted this voice heard.
It was actually really touching the outpouring of support. So thank you.
If you were part of it, but like that boring. I was bored yesterday. I was like,
wow. I'm like, that's so, uh, it was hilarious.
People that will need it on you forever.
People have hated on you forever on MSNBC. I'll remain nameless,
but they came out and they were like, Andrew, Yang's beyond it.
This is ridiculous. Like that to me was, um,
I don't know, funny and kind of case in point.
Gratifying, I was like, Oh, thank you. That's so kind of really like,
it did reflect on it for a minute. Um, because, uh, you know,
there are other folks that are also not on the program that ran and, um,
the fact that there doesn't seem to be much of an outcry.
It was really touching to me. I was like, Oh wow.
Like people recognize what we did. Yeah.
So thank you to everyone who helped me make that happen. Um, yeah.
We're, we're keeping, making things happening every day.
Twitter went nuts. Here we are. We'll be involved in the convention somehow.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.